تُعرف باسم الأسلحة
الهجومية وقد تم استخدامها في بعض عمليات
إطلاق النار الأكثر دموية في البلاد من
uvalde tulsa و el paso إلى منتزه سان
برناردينو و Sandy Hook ،
كانت البندقية الهجومية ذات القوة العالية هي
السلاح المفضل للعديد من القتلة.
حار
قسم شرطة لوس أنجلوس
يوضح لنا بندقية نصف آلية من طراز ar
بالنسبة لنا في نطاق بندقية القسم ،
لديك برميل من 16 بوصة إلى 20 بوصة ،
لديك مخزون مكتمل ،
وستكون دقيقًا على
مسافات بعيدة
بدلاً من ذلك.  إلى مسدس ناهيك عن ذكره
مثل بعض الأسلحة الأخرى ، يمكنه إطلاق
رصاصة بقوة كافية لاختراق
درع الجسم الناعم ، وهو شيء يعرفه الرقيب جيمس
زابرافان بشكل مباشر يا يسوع ،
إنه بالتأكيد سلاح آلي أطلق عليه
نيران أسلحة هجومية خلال إطلاق النار في
شمال هوليوود الشهير عام 1997
حيث  قام اثنان من لصوص البنوك يرتديان
دروع واقية بإطلاق النار على الشرطة لمدة ساعة تقريبًا
مما أدى إلى إصابة ثمانية أشخاص و 12 ضابطًا
بمن فيهم رقباء بوروفان.
ضربنا
بقطع من المركبات التي كنا نختبئها
خلف
سائل مشعاع الإسفلت ، شعرنا وكأننا
نلدغ من قبل النحل الذي
أدى إلى تغيير سياسة إطلاق النار مما دفع اللابد والإدارات الأخرى
إلى ترقية
أسلحتهم الخاصة لمواجهة
البنادق القوية المتزايدة التي يستخدمها المهاجمون.
تمت دراسة الأسلحة
داخل مختبر المقذوفات في جامعة واين ستيت
حيث يقوم الباحثون بمحاكاة
تأثير الرصاصة على جسم الإنسان ، وهي عبارة عن
كتلة من الجيلاتين بنسبة 20 في المائة ، وهي
تهدف إلى تمثيل الأنسجة البشرية ، لذا
تراقب الأنسجة الرخوة بينما
يطلق فريق سينثيا بور مسدسًا في الساعة 1  000 قدم
في الثانية في كتلة الجيلاتين
لهذه الجولة بالذات ، سترى
الرصاصة تأتي في هذا الجانب ، ترى هذا
التجويف المؤقت يحدث هنا بحيث يكون هذا
التمدد هو ما يحدث في الجسم
ثم ينهار ، ومن هنا
يأتي الضرر.  شاهد الآن
بينما يطلق الفريق النار من بندقية هجومية ،
نرى المزيد من الاضطراب في هذه
الجولة في الواقع تكسرها.  لا
تخرج ، لذا فهي تبلغ حوالي 3000 قدم في
الثانية وتذهب كل هذه الطاقة إلى
الأنسجة الرخوة ،
لدينا قطعة من البلاستيك هنا
لنعكسها لعمل مقاطع الفيديو وقد
رفعت البلاستيك عن الطاولة
مع الطاقة الناتجة عن الصورة اللاحقة  من
طلقة المسدس يظهر
خطًا مستقيمًا نسبيًا عبر الأنسجة التي تخرج
من الجانب الآخر
ولكن ليس كذلك مع الجولة من AR-15 ،
فإنها تذهب أساسًا إلى الجسم
وتحدث انفجارًا داخل الجسم ،
ويقول الجراحون إن الجرح الناجم عن
بندقية هجومية يمكن  تكون
كارثية وأسوأ جزء في الطفل ، جميع
الأعضاء الحيوية قريبة
جدًا من بعضها ، لذا فإن كل واحدة من هذه الرصاصات تسبب
لك ضررًا لا رجعة فيه في أسر تكساس المتطورة ،
وقد طُلب من مسحات الحمض النووي
لمساعدة السلطات على التعرف على
أطفالهم كأم حقًا  يؤثر علي بشكل
صحيح
لأنني لا أستطيع أن أتخيل أن يكون هناك طفل يتحمل
هذا ومع المجلات عالية السعة
يمكن للمشتبه بهم التصوير لفترة أطول بكثير
الآن النقاش حول مجلة عالية السعة
تركز بشكل كبير على
تقليل مقدار الوقت الذي يمكن أن يطلقه المشتبه به
دون الحاجة إلى إعادة التحميل
كعامل FBI سابق ، لقد تم تدريبنا
على إعادة تحميل سلاحك بسرعة ونسخه
احتياطيًا على الهدف ولكن بالنسبة لمشتبه به على
سبيل المثال لم يتم تدريبه ، يمكنك ذلك  انظر إلى
استخدام سلاح التدريب هذا ، وهي
عملية تتضمن إزالة الخزنة الفارغة
والحصول على جولة جديدة من
الذخيرة يتم تحميلها في السلاح
لشحن السلاح وإعادته
إلى الهدف ، فهذه كلها ثوان ثمينة
حيث يمكن للضحايا الفرار من البندقية يمكن أن
تتكدس أو  يمكن أن يشترك المشتبه به من قبل
تطبيق القانون أو المارة الذين
يعرفون أن الضرر الذي تسببه قوة النيران المستمرة
يمكن أن يجعل الباحثين يأملون أن
تؤدي نتائجهم الحاسمة إلى الوعي
بغض النظر عن المكان الذي يأتي فيه المرء إلى
الجدل حول السيطرة على الأسلحة ، فلا جدال في
أن سلاح الهجوم يسبب
ضررًا كبيرًا داخل الجسم
بالتأكيد ولكن هذا هو الواقع
هذا ما يحدث